is a simmering view between Dwayne
Johnson and Vin Diesel finally calling
here's how a new director and a backroom
peace treaty brought Hobbes back into
the fast forward spoilers ahead for
faster X it's been a long and bumpy road
for fast X but the latest entry in
Universal Pictures billion dollar
franchise has finally raced its way into
Cinemas after director Justin Lin
stepped away from the film during the
early days of production Louis laterrier
was quickly brought on board to helm the
picture the French filmmaker has proven
to be a wonderful asset for Universal
bringing fast decks to completion if
that wasn't enough audiences of the
terrier to thank when it comes to
squashing the beef between Dwayne
Johnson and Vin Diesel back in 2021
Johnson put his foot down and made it
clear that his time with Fast and
Furious was over he revealed to CNN I
told Vin Diesel directly and privately
that I would not be returning to the
franchise I was firm yet cordial with my
words and said that I would always be
supportive of the cast and always root
for the franchise to be successful but
that there was no chance I would return
Daddy's staying home Johnson's words
seem definitive at the time confirming
that hobbs's relationship with the first
fam was a closed chapter however just a
week before fast exit Cinemas it was
confirmed that Johnson would be
returning for the film's mid-credits
scene Dwayne Johnson's return to the
fast franchise is nothing short of a
cinematic Miracle Luke Hobbs has stood
out as one of the franchises most
complex and chaotic characters having
made his debut back in fast 5. he'd go
on to be a key player in Fast and
Furious 6 Furious 7 fate of the Furious
and the spin-off Hobson Shore though he
missed F9 this prompted hardcore fans
the vocally Express their displeasure
over the increasingly prominent
character's absence Louis letterier
clearly understands just how important
Hobbs is to The Saga and fans explaining
to The Hollywood Reporter that it was
important to figure out a way to bury
the hatchet between Johnson and Vin
Diesel he said the peace treaty I kind
of broken it we all did ultimately the
movie Dead we sort of looked at each
other from across the room and winked a
few months back saying we should work
together sure Johnson's return is Hobbs
are soon set in motion with the terrier
coming up with a plan to seamlessly
bring the actor and his character back
into the phone the director continued by
saying that he approached Universal and
the film's producers with his idea of
how hubs could be reintroduced to the
universe in Fast Access mid-credits
scene The elusive Hobbes received a
phone call from the film's villain the
over-the-top Dante Reyes who lets them
know that the special agent is at the
top of his Hit List thus it seems that
big things are in store for Hobbes as a
fast Saga rubs up
worth billions huh
yes it is once the fastex helmet got the
thumbs up for the threatening mid credit
scene it was time to approach Black Adam
himself that Terrier explained and then
we reached out to Dwayne and his team
and said just come and watch the movie
you have to love the movie First turns
out the rock was a fan of what the
terrier was cooking which compelled him
to return his Huffs that Terrier wrapped
up his discussion of the process by
saying was in a lot of fans Minds it was
very smooth and frankly as a fan I could
not conceive continuing the franchise
without either Dwayne or Gal Gadot that
has got to go to work